what is the standard deviation the
standard deviation is a measure that
indicates how much data scatter around
the mean here's a simple example let's
say we measure the height of a small
group of people the standard deviation
tells us how much our data scatter
around the mean so first we need to
calculate the mean let's say we get a
mean value of
155 centimeters now we want to know how
much each person deviates from the mean
but we are not interested in the
deviation of each individual person from
the mean value we want to know how much
the persons on average deviate from the
mean value so how much do these persons
on average deviate from the mean value
this is what the standard deviation
tells us in our example the average
deviation from the mean value is 11.5
centimeters